it's only when the second defender comes  to you leave the open three-point  shooter and  damien's a good defender he knows better  than that you can't help off the strong  side you also can't turn your body  around  lose sight of your man it's usually but  to the baseline wow that's  that's gonna be a timeout that's that  shouldn't happen at any level it was  malachi flynn and a half court set went  right to the rim and so  steve kerr and jaren collins everybody's  gonna talk about this there's a long way  to go in this game  it's become the the tonight this is a  continuation of  atlanta and sacramento that just you  trying to avoid that but  30 means that much and then draymond on  top of it  and then oh by the way the other splash  brother  your three best players missing that's  why the lakers look like a lottery